(soft percussive music)
- [Reporter] A record number
of young people in China
graduated from college this year,
but instead of celebrating...
(camera shutter clicking)
Some are marking the
milestone on social media
by lying down flat on the ground
in their graduation gowns,
looking dejected and exhausted.
After studying for
years, they're frustrated
with the struggle to find decent work
as China's youth unemployment
rate hits historic highs.
So for some, the better option for now
is to stay at home as
so-called full-time children.
- If you have a lot of idle young people
who are not employed, it adds
pressure on social stability
which is what the government
really is concerned about.
- [Reporter] Here's
why millions of Chinese
graduates are out of work.
The term full-time children has gone viral
on Chinese social media.
Videos show young people spending time
with their parents, cooking and cleaning
in exchange for a salary.
(son speaks Chinese)
- They are choosing to
stay at home full time.
They are counting on their parents
to continue support them financially.
This is what many people are referring to
as the 'lying flat' phenomenon In China
- [Reporter] Lying flat essentially means
to resist the intense social pressure
to study hard and work even harder.
A record 11.6 million young Chinese
graduated from college this year,
almost 12 times more than 20 years ago.
- Students, they have
much higher expectation
for their job income, their job stability,
and what they can derive by doing work.
- [Reporter] But the graduates soon found,
they're competing with thousands of others
for only a handful of jobs
that match their skills and expectations.
Urban youth unemployment
hit a record 21.3% in June.
Joblessness in China increased
dramatically in recent years
while other countries such
as the U.S. saw a spike
in youth unemployment during the pandemic
that rapidly fell as
restrictions were eased.
China maintained COVID controls for longer
than most countries,
keeping its borders closed
from 2020 to early 2023.
Major cities went through
extended lockdowns
that disrupted production.
As the economy slowed, so too, did hiring.
China's youth unemployment rates rose
for six consecutive months this year.
Then in August, the
government abruptly announced
that it would stop reporting that data,
citing plans to revisit the methodology.
Analysts say the suspension
fits a worrying pattern
of haziness around the true
state of China's economy.
To address the youth unemployment problem,
local governments ordered
state-owned companies
to hire more graduates.
They're also pushing young people
to take up blue-collared work,
but that's unappealing for
a lot of college graduates.
A survey from online recruitment platform,
Zhaopin, found that a quarter
of this year's graduates
want to work in the technology sector,
despite the fact that some
of China's biggest tech firms
had massive layoffs following a regulatory
crackdown on the industry.
- [Stella Xie] So unless
confidence revive in those sectors,
young college graduates will
likely continue to struggle
in terms of what kind of work
they're looking for to do.
- Down the line, having
millions of young people
out of work will have serious
ripple effects for China's society.
- High jobless rate among young people
also exacerbate many other
structural challenges
that China already is dealing with.
For example, without stable jobs,
many people are putting
off getting married.
They don't wanna have kids,
and all these will make
China's demographic situation even worse.
- [Reporter] Some are
warning of a lost generation.
It's adding to a long list
of challenges for Beijing
to boost growth and
attract foreign investors
as the world's second largest economy
tries to rebuild from the pandemic.
(soft music)